E
IS ENDURING THE WORST DAYS OF
THE WAR SINCE THE FALL OF
MARIUPOL.
>> Reporter: NEW ROUNDS SOON TO
BE LOADED INTO THE BREACH.
THESE UKRAINIAN TROOPS WAIT FOR
THE ORDER.
THEY'RE PREPARING TO ORDER THIS
GUN.
UKRAINE HAS RECEIVED MORE THAN
100 M-777 HOWITZERS, BUT THE
RUSSIANS ARE GAINING MORE AND
MORE GROUND.
THIS HELPS, BUT IT MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH.
THIS SOPHISTICATED U.S.-MADE 155
MILLIMETER HOWITZER, UKRAINE
HOPES TO COUNTER RUSSIA'S
MASSIVE SUPERIORITY IN
FIREPOWER.
THAT SUPERIORITY HAS ALLOWED
RUSSIAN FORCES TO PUSH FORWARD,
SUBJECTING CITIES LIKE
SEVERODONETSK TO INTENSE
BOMBARDMENT.
THIS DRONE FOOTAGE SHOWS RUSSIAN
TANKS ENTERING THIS TOWN, JUST
OUTSIDE OF SEVERODONETSK.
OUTNUMBERED AND OUTGUNNED,
UKRAINE HAS WARNED RUSSIA MAY
SOON INTENSIFY THEIR ATTACK.
THIS ARTILLERY IS FIRING ROUNDS
WITH A RANGE OF AROUND 20
KILOMETERS, OR 12.5 MILES.
THE TARGET, WE'RE TOLD, RUSSIAN
ARMOR PERSONNEL CARRIERS.
THANKS TO THE AMERICANS, WE CAN
WIN THIS WAR.
BUT WE NEED MORE ARTILLERY AND
MORE AMMUNITION.
OR IN PLAIN ENGLISH --
>> WE NEED YOUR HELP.
>> Reporter: HIS COMRADE PUTS A
NUMBER TO IT.
"WE NEED LEAST 500 OF THESE
GUNS," HE SAYS.
THIS HAS BECOME AN ARTILLERY
WAR, AND VICTORY WILL COME FROM
THE BARREL OF A GUN.
AND WE HAD TO LEAVE THAT AREA
VERY QUICKLY, WOLF, BECAUSE
THERE'S FEAR OF RUSSIAN DRONES
OVERHEAD.
WE KNOW THAT ONE OF THOSE M-